What I want to do in this video
is take an expenditure view
of GDP, so that we can think
about how GDP can be accounted
for, how it can be
measured, and how
we can see how active the
different parts of an economy
actually are.
So GDP, market value of all
final goods and services
produced, not just
changed hands,
produced within a country
in a given period.
And the symbol we use for
GDP, and I don't know why,
but the symbol is Y. Y is GDP.
And so let's think about it from
an expenditure point of view,
to think about what
are all the pieces.
Well, if we're thinking
about expenditure,
who are all of the players
that might have spent money
on the goods and services,
on final goods and services,
produced in our country?
Who are all the people
that might have done it?
Well, you could have your firms.
The firms might have spent money
on these goods and services
produced in a country.
You also have your households.
They obviously could've
spent some money
on goods and services
produced in this country.
Then you also have
in most countries,
in fact in all countries,
you have the government.
The government could have
spent some of the money
on the goods and services
produced in this country.
And if we assume that we're
trading with other countries,
there are other countries
that might have spent money
on goods and services.
Other, outside, so let's
just write foreign.
People outside of the country
might have spent money
on goods and services,
so foreign purchases.
And another way to
think about this
would have been this is exports.
Our country is exporting it to
people outside of the country
and they are purchasing it.
Now, this is almost complete.
But if we looked
at all of the money
that firms are spending and all
the money that households are
spending and all the money
that governments are spending,
some of what they're
spending might not
be on goods and services that
are produced in this country.
They might be spending
some of their stuff
on things that are produced
outside of this country.
So we would have
to subtract it out
if we really want to have the
goods and services produced
within the country.
So what we're
going to want to do
is subtract out
foreign products.
Or another way, the more typical
way of thinking about it,
we would subtract out imports.
So if we think about all of
the goods and services that
meet this classification,
the final goods and services
produced in a country
in a given time,
that firms spent
money on, and add that
to all the goods and services
that households spent money on,
and add that to all the goods
and services that government
spent on, and all the goods and
services that were purchased
by foreigners, the
exports, and then
make sure we're not counting
the goods and services
that other countries produce--
so we subtract those out-- this
would give you a
pretty good measure
of all of the goods and services
produced within a country.
And this is pretty close to
the way the economists actually
do measure it.
So what they do is they say
Y is equal to investment.
And we saw in a previous
video, investment
in the macroeconomics
term isn't quite
what it means in
the everyday term.
It really essentially means
the spending by firms.
So pretty much everything
that a firm spends in theory,
you're spending that money to
make future goods and services,
or to make the
goods and services--
so that's all
considered investment.
And then a little bit of
the household spending
is considered investment.
And that is just new houses.
But the bulk of
household spending
is considered to be consumption.
And then everything that
the government spends on,
whether it's the military and
all the salaries for police
people and whatever
they do, you know,
the groundskeeping
at the White House,
whatever else, if we
thinking about the US, that
goes straight to G,
government spending.
And this thing
right over here, you
have foreign purchases,
exports, minus foreign imports.
So you have exports
minus imports.
So you could view
this as net exports.
If this number is positive,
the net exports are positive.
We're exporting more
than we're importing.
If this number is negative,
net exports is negative.
That means we are importing
more than we are exporting.
But in traditional
expenditure view of GDP,
this whole part
right over here will
be referred to as net exports.
And so you sum up these things,
which are very closely related
to maybe the slightly
more intuitive versions
that we started off
with, and you essentially
have broken down the
expenditure view of GDP
in the traditional sense.
Then in the next few
videos, I'm going
to start thinking of a
bunch of different examples.
And we'll think about which
bucket it would fall into
or how it would affect
one of these buckets.